let's talk a little bit about chemical
reactions and chemical reactions are a
very big deal without chemical reactions
you or i would not exist in your body
right now there are countless chemical
reactions going on every second without
chemical reactions we would have no life
we would not even have the the universe
as we know it so what are chemical
reactions well there any time that you
have bonds being formed or broken
between atoms or molecules so what do we
what do we what are we talking about
there
well this is
maybe one of the most fundamental
chemical reactions once again if this
one never occurred we'd be in trouble we
would not have we would not have any
water but let's think about what it is
actually describing so over here on the
left hand side we have the reactants let
me write that down
so here we have the reactants these are
the molecules that are going to react
and then we have an arrow that moves us
to the product
so let me do that in a different color
so we have an arrow that moves us
to the product or that we could say the
products and so what are the reactants
here
well we have molecular hydrogen and we
have molecular oxygen now why did i say
molecular hydrogen because molecular
hydrogen which is the state that you
would typically find hydrogen in if you
just have it by itself is actually made
up of two hydrogen atoms you see it
right over here one two hydrogen atoms
and what we have in order to have this
reaction you don't just need one
molecular hydrogen and one or one
molecule of hydrogen one molecule of
oxygen for every for for this reaction
to happen you actually have two
molecules of molecular hydrogen so this
is actually made up of four hydrogen
atoms so let me make this clear so this
right over here
this is two molecules of molecular
hydrogen and that's why we have the two
right out front of the h sub two the
this little subscript two tells us
there's two of the hydrogen atoms in
this molecule and then this big this big
white two that we have right over here
that tells us that we're dealing with
two of those molecules for this reaction
to happen that we need two of these
molecules for every
for every molecule of molecular oxygen
and molecular oxygen once again this is
composed of two oxygen atoms one two
so under the right conditions so you
need a little bit of energy to make this
happen
if under the right conditions these two
things are going to react and actually
it's very very reactive molecular
hydrogen molecular oxygen so much so
that it's actually used for rocket fuel
you are going to produce two molecules
of water we see that right over here
and look i did not create or destroy any
atoms i had one
i had
one
i had one oxygen atom here
it was part of the oxygen molecule right
right here then i have the second one
right over here now now they are part of
separate molecules i had
i had a i had one two three four
hydrogens i now have one
two
three
four hydrogens just like that and
actually this produces a so we could say
some energy and i'm being inexact right
over here
some energy
and then we could say a lot of energy a
lot
of energy so this is a reaction that you
just give it a little bit of a kick
start and it really wants to happen
a lot
a lot of energy so one thing that you
might wonder and this is something that
i first wondered when i learned about
reactions well how do
how does this happen is this is a very
organized thing or you know do these do
do these molecules somehow know to to
react with each other and the answer is
no
chemistry is an incredibly messy thing
you have these things bouncing around
they have energy they they're bouncing
around all over the place and actually
when you provide energy they're going to
bounce around even more rigorously
enough so that they
they they collide in the right ways so
that they they break their old bonds and
then they form these new bonds so
whenever you see these reactions in
biology or chemistry class keep that in
mind it looks all neat and organized but
in a real system these are these are all
of these things just bouncing around in
all different crazy ways and that's why
energy is an important thing here
because the more energy you apply to the
system the more that they're going to
bounce around the more that they're
going to interact with each other the
more reactants you put in
the more chance that they're going to
bounce around and be able to react with
each other now i'm going to introduce
another word that you're going to see in
chemistry a lot this this water these
two we see we have two
water molecules here we could call them
molecules but since they are actually
made up of two or more different
elements we could also call this a
compound so water
water is you could call it a molecule or
you could call it a compound so this is
a molecule or compound while this
molecular hydrogen you would not call
this a compound and this molecular
oxygen of course it's a molecule but you
would not call it a compound either and
just to to get an appreciation of how
much energy this produces let me show
you this picture right over here that's
the space shuttle and this this big tank
right over here let me
this big tank
contains a bunch of liquid oxygen and
hydrogen and to create this incredible
this incredible amount of energy it
actually just you you you mix the two
together with a little bit of a with a
little bit energy and then you produce a
ton of energy that makes that makes the
rocket that makes the space shuttle
while space shuttle's been discontinued
now but back when they did it to make it
to make it uh get get its it's necessary
it's necessary velocity
now let's talk about the idea so you
know this this reaction strongly goes in
this in in the direction of going to
water but it can actually go the other
way but it's very very hard for it to go
the other way so in general we would
consider this to be an irreversible
reaction even though it is you know
irreversible sounds like hey you can't
go the other way it just really means
that it's very unlikely to go the other
way you have to supply a lot of energy
to go the other way to make this
reaction go the other way you'd have to
do something called electrolysis you're
providing energy et cetera et cetera but
in general the way that this is written
because the arrow is only pointing in
one direction this is implying that it
is irreversible irreversible
irreversible which probably makes you
think well what about reversible
reactions and i have a i have an example
of a reversible reaction
right over here i have a i have one
bicarbonate ion and the word ion that's
just to use to describe any molecule or
atom that has either has an imbalance of
electrons or protons that cause it to
have a net charge so this makes this an
ion and actually right over here this is
a hydrogen this is a hydrogen ion right
over here both of these are charged one
has a positive charge one has a negative
charge but they are both
they are both ions and this reaction
right over here you have the bicarbonate
ion that looks something like this this
is just my my hand drawing of it
reacting with a hydrogen ion it's really
a hydrogen atom that has lost its
electrons so some people would even say
this is a this is a proton right over
here this is an equilibrium reaction
where it can form carbonic acid and
notice all that's happening is this
hydrogen is attaching to one of the
oxygens over here and this is an
equilibrium because if in an actual an
actual solution it's going back and
forth if you actually provide more
reactants you're going to go more in
that direction if you provide more of
the products over here then you're going
to go you're going to go in that
direction and so in an actual if in an
actual environment in an actual system
it's constantly going back and forth
between these two things and different
reversible reactions might tend to one
side or the other if you provide more
more of the stuff on one side it might
go more in the other direction because
these are going to they're going to be
more likely to interact or if you
provide more of this it might go in the
other direction because these because
these might more likely react with their
surroundings or disassociate
in some way
now just to get a sense of you know it's
nice to kind of you know are these just
some random letters that i wrote here
carbonic acid is actually an incredibly
important molecule or we could call it a
compound because it's made up of two or
two or more elements in in living
systems and in fact you know even even
even in the environment and even when
you go out to get some fast food when
you have carbonated drinks it has
carbonic acid in it that disassociates
into carbon dioxide and that carbon
dioxide is what you see bubbling up
carbonic acid is incredibly important in
how your body deals with excess excess
carbon dioxide in its bloodstream
carbonic acid is involved in in the
oceans taking up carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere so when you're studying
chemistry especially in the context of
biology these aren't just you know
interesting things that seem very
academic these are affecting your real
life and your body and your environment